this is a production of Cornell
University
all right so thank you for showing up
today and thank you for giving me a
chance to talk to you about my research
as Joyce said I work for the USTA up in
Geneva and I work on grapevines my
position is as a research geneticist and
the USDA we have these specific sort of
regions that we work on and mine is
abiotic stress tolerance and because of
our location in western New York the
most important abiotic stress from
grapevines point of view is winter
stress cold stress so here you can see a
vineyard just south of Geneva in the
middle of winter and you can see that
it's very beautiful it's a really fun
place to work if you have the
appropriate clothing but from the vines
point of view this is very stressful so
there's no there's no canopy there's no
foliage the vine shut down is doing its
very best to survive complexity of
winter temperatures and make it to
spring so we're gonna go over a whole
bunch of concepts but that's the basic
overwhelming part of my talk is how do
grapevines make it through winter before
we go very far I just want to
acknowledge my student al Kowalewski a
lot of what I'm gonna present today has
come out of his thesis he's really
pushed this program in a way that I
didn't didn't think it was gonna go and
it's been really great so he's he's the
Brawn behind this and the brain behind
most of this talk so we're gonna
introduce grapevine Vitis vinifera is
the cultivated form of grape that gives
us these four wonderful end products at
the base here that was advancing this
slide here you go wine table grapes
juice grapes and raisins the vast
majority of global production comes from
this one species this species was
domesticated from its wild ancestor
sylvestris in the mediterranean region
of europe and this is important to us
from a winter temperature point of view
and an adaptation point of view because
if you look at what the minimum
temperatures along the Mediterranean
coast are you can see that they're not
that bad red and orange is negative 1 to
4 C for red and so these are these are
very mild winters from our perspective
so the hot dry summer cool mild winter
and so there's not a lot of need for
strong freezers
in these in Vitis vinifera it still
doesn't do a bad job of surviving winter
it can survive two temperatures about
negative 13 F I'm gonna primarily speak
in Celsius because that's how we take
our measurements so negative 25 degrees
Celsius is sort of the limit negative 13
degrees Fahrenheit so we care about cold
hardiness because temperature is one of
the leading factors that limit where we
can grow the crops that we grow and and
for sure for grape vines so here you can
see in this map this little black star
in the top right corner that's Geneva
and this arc is the 44th North latitude
that goes through France and Italy so
our latitude is comparable with the
Mediterranean but you can see by the
color graph we're nowhere near that red
and brown coloring it's much colder here
the value of the New York grape industry
is somewhere between 52 and 70 million
dollars and if we have a really bad
winter you can suffer up to 50 million
dollars worth of damage that depends
very much on the type of winter where it
strikes if you go into the Midwest they
can have almost complete crop loss from
a bad winter in New York we tend to grow
grapes in very specific regions in the
bottom map here and purple are the
primary wine regions there's two colors
of purple I'm not sure if you can see
the lavender but if you look at the
hardiness map those purple areas overlap
completely with the green areas in the
hardness map that's cuz we grow
cultivated grape right on its margin
we're at a spot where you cannot be sure
that Vitis vinifera will survive every
single year low temperature associated
stresses affect Vitis vinifera globally
so here's a map in purple our high frost
risk areas and so with this particular
aspect of cold hardiness we're talking
about the buds breaking early in spring
before the last threat of Frost has
passed if you have a frost it freezes
off you're growing tissues which include
your flowers means no crop so you can
see it affects it globally
but this interplays a lot with the way
that global climate is starting to shift
so here pictured in red areas in
California the Northeast and in Europe
our areas where we grow grapes now or
could grow grapes now climatically that
are expected to get too hot in the
summer to produce grapes and they're
going to shift towards these blue areas
in each case when you shift north that
may give us the right summer
temperatures but that puts us at risk of
more winter temperatures because they
doesn't necessarily mean warmer all the
time we have seen that winters are
getting warmer about in our region about
1 degree fahrenheit per decade and so
from 1970 we've warmed Y about 5 or 6
degrees Fahrenheit if you look at the
trend of the minimum winter temperatures
it is also going up and so it's getting
warmer and our winter extremes are
getting less but I also want to point
out here that the range in winters
extreme winter extremes goes from
negative 19 to 6 degrees so while it may
be warmer overall the variation in those
killing events is still very high so
when you put those together it becomes
very problematic for consistent
grapevine production this plays into how
global change and warming winters
affects the risk of freeze immense
normally a strong Jetstream protects
arctic air keeps it trapped at the poles
but as we warm in winter particularly in
the Arctic that jet stream gets weaker
which is shown here and that arctic air
can break out more often and we see that
manifest here in this third graph this
was the polar vortex when polar vortex
became a thing again a couple years ago
we had this breakout of polar air breaks
out of polar air that plunge down
through the Midwest caused a lot of
damage in a lot of crops and this is the
sort of event that will kill grapes
because if they get a mild winter
they're not prepared for this drastic
switch the way that we have been dealing
with this challenge on the margins is by
breeding new cold hardy hybrids and so
we use wild grapevine species in the
genus Vitus in North America there's
probably about 20 different varieties
and in Asia there's probably another 40
pictured here are some distribution maps
for different wild grape species and
this is a
the fruit we typically use Vitus ripe
area which hopefully you can tell the
difference in the green here the lime
green is the county level distribution
it's a very widespread species that goes
well up into Canada it happens to be one
of the most cold hardy species that
survives the coldest temperatures and
wild grape can survive to around
negative 35 to negative 40 C so it's
about a 10 to 15 degree C increase in
ability to survive winters so all of our
cultivar improvement for freeze
resistance comes from these wild species
we can't breed cold hardiness out of
vanilla it simply doesn't have the tools
so we talked about winter it's also very
complex we're talking about half of the
year at least maybe about eight months
extends from fall through the dormancy
period of winter into spring bud burst
during the time during this whole time
we have a number of different cold
related stresses frost is very important
in the fall and in the spring if you get
an early frost in the fall you can do
foliate the vine and that cuts off its
ability to prepare for winter if you get
a frost in the spring you lose sorry
about this or you lose your floral
tissue you can also have cold extremes
throughout the winter and if the vine
isn't prepared an early mid or late
winter you can suffer bud damage and
that has the same effect as killing the
flowers
we typically represent this as the
lethal temperature and it follows this
shape throughout winter the ability to
survive freezing increases in early
winter it's maintained through mid
winter and then lost quickly in the
spring so we call this acclamation
maximum hardness or maintenance and D
acclamation
so these are the two major concepts for
today dormancy and cold hardiness
dormancy is the period of the vine
basically being asleep keeping its
growth from occurring during
temperatures that are not growth
permissible it's necessary for grapevine
to go through this for it to have
synchronous bud burst and synchronous
flowering in the spring and the other
concept is cold hardiness which is very
complex but it involves freeze hardiness
freeze tolerance super cooling a bunch
of different factors that all go into
the general idea of the vine survives
all the freezing events of that year so
we do all of our work on dormant wood
and specifically with the bud and so
these are cuttings of grape each cut
into a single node and so there's a
little bud here we'll see some zum-zum
ends later but we do all of our work
taking samples from the field and
they're doing growth chamber experiments
so the primary aspect of my research
program is to full actually describing
the phenotype of what cold hardiness is
because this is something that's super
complex and we need to be able to target
aspects of it and I think of it as four
things how does the vine prepare for
winter how does it prevent changes in
physiology that result in growth how
does it survive sub-freezing
temperatures and then how does it time
bud burst in the spring so those four
factors are the phenotypes as from the
genetic point of view we want to know
what the genetic architecture of all
these traits are what we know from all
abiotic stresses is that it's Polly Gena
lots of different genes playing roles
and if we look at other literature we
see that cold often uses the same stress
pathways as salt drought heat and ABA
exposure and so basically the idea is
that all these abiotic stresses activate
a suite of transcription factors that
activated an even larger suite of
downstream genes to cause changes in the
plant and so we expect a lot of
crosstalk when we start unraveling some
of the genes behind this we expect to
find things for drought and for salinity
so if we cover a little bit of some of
these terms just so we're all in the
same page we want to talk a little bit
about dormancy and children chilling a
requirement the bud is a really
interesting entity and that it is
isolated from the rest of the vine
during the winter it's sealed off and is
able to measure the length of winter it
measures it through some sort of clock
system that we don't quite understand
but that clock runs between 0 and 11
degrees Celsius and so when the
temperatures outside drop below 11
degrees Celsius the bunk buds start
counting when it drops below freezing
they stop over the winter they need to
accumulate a certain amount in order to
be ready to grow in the spring and so if
you go out to the field and you grab a
cutting while this clock is running and
you put in the greenhouse it won't grow
this is called endo dormancy a specific
type of dormancy SAR internal dormancy
where physiology some physiological
parameters suppressing growth at some
point the clock is fulfilled and the
buds transition to something called eco
dormancy where if you go and you take
that bud and then remove it from the
field say in February it's still too
cold to grow but you put it inside will
now grow so this suppression has been
released and now dormancy is enforced by
the temperature at least two different
interactions these two different
dormancy parameters the length of that
brown bar the endo dormancy barrier can
be determined by genetic differences so
different species can have different
amounts of that clock and it can also be
determined by the environment so if you
have a very cold location the clock
needs to run a long time because you
don't spend a lot of time in that
temperature zone if you have a very mild
climate the clock is always running so
that arrow relatively speaking gets
smaller this is important because if you
transition to this eco dormant state in
an area that gets late winter
snap-freezes you can damage the vine so
once it moves into this eco dormant
state it's much more set sensitive we
measure this by taking cuttings putting
them into a growth chamber giving them
doses of chill and then seeing how long
it takes them to grow and when they're
fully when they're chilling requirement
is fully met
all burst synchronously when it's not
fully met you get a synchronous burst
this is a problem in the field because
if you get a synchronous first you get a
synchronous flowering and fruiting and
farmers don't like to have to harvest at
multiple times data wise if you plot the
days of budburst versus the chilling
hours you get this relationship the more
chilling that vine gets in that clock
region the faster it gets it growing if
you also look at it this way it also
gets more synchronous so these two
parameters are combined so when you're
planting a certain variety you have to
keep dormancy in the chilling
requirement in mind because not all
varieties can be grown everywhere from
this standpoint alone if you look at the
chilling hours that accumulate across
the United States you can see here in in
western New York we get lots 1,500 hours
that's because we've got the Great Lakes
the Finger Lakes in the ocean nearby it
makes us very mild if you look in North
and South Dakota they have less chilling
hours than we do even though their
winter is much harsher than us because
that clock is is stopped it's below
freezing so if you plant a high chill
variety in North or South Dakota it's
not going to break but on time the same
thing happens when the South is too warm
and we don't get a peach harvest if you
don't get enough chilling for peaches or
apples for all these different group
crops you won't get synchronous bursts
and synchronous fruiting if we just look
quickly at two years 2012 2013 was warm
for us we had 1,600 hours of chill by
the end of the winter whereas in South
Dakota at the same time point they only
had a thousand so here you would be able
to plant varieties that have chilling
hours that require a lot of chilling if
you plan it in South Dakota it won't
work if you go to a cold year you can
see that here we lost 300 hours so we
have to be very aware of the chilling
requirements of the crops that we plant
because you can inadvertently plant
something that's not going to do well
here from reduction point of view
if we then look at different wild
grapevines species we see that that
response is shared across all wild
species all wild species get faster at
growing with increasing gel but their
position on the y-axis both at the start
of winter and at the end is different
and so there are differences in the
chill response high medium and low and
if we look at them geographically by the
distribution it looks like southern
species typically need longer winters
than northern species this seems like a
bit of a paradox because you would think
that own orleans be she would want to be
prepared for a long winter but this is
from the point of view of that clock so
a northern winter is actually a very
short clock winter that makes sense so
what we see here is a potential adaptive
trait based on on geography so we can
now target these different species for
different dormancy chilling requirement
aspects and I'm gonna bring your
attention back to ripe area because we
use ripe area a lot for cold hardiness
you can see that it's on the northern
distribution low chill response side in
the germplasm and genève i've access to
lots of different accessions from across
the country and so we looked at 43 of
these and if we group them into southern
and northern groups and you squint a
little bit at it you can see that the
blue is on the lower side and the Gert
and the orange is on the upper side so
it looks like and then this the color
coding is preserved here in this column
it looks like things from the south
tend to have slightly longer dormancy so
it looks like that species level
distribution in north to south is
possibly preserved within widely
dispersed species as well so there may
be a gradient within ripe area for the
same trait so this is cool because now
we have ripe areas that we can use to
breed for longer winters and we want
that for up here because we have what
what the clock thinks is a really long
winter
so we're now working with the grapevine
breeder and Cornell to use some of this
material for breeding rather than
choosing the stuff from Manitoba which
is believed to be very cold hardy but
has a very short requirement so dormancy
protects the buds from growing when the
temperatures are lethal there's two
parts of dormancy to protect against
temperature and there's one portion
where it's protecting against
temperature and there's another portion
words very responsive to temperature the
dormancy level in the chilling
requirement is important for what types
of cultivars you plant and it looks like
there's a geographic gradient for this
tree so that's kind of cool to me from a
sort of like a natural adaptation and
natural evolution kind of point of view
the other part of my research that
overlaps with dormancy is the ability of
the blood to survive freezing events
this is a picture of a grapevine bud
that has been cut and then split open
okay so this is the base of the bud here
and this is sort of like the decapitated
top of the bud right in the center there
is a dead primary bud there's a there's
it's a compound bud there's three buds
in there the primary the secondary and
the tertiary the primary is the weakest
and has the floral tissue for the next
year in this particular picture you can
see the primary is dead and oxidized and
the secondary and tertiary are still
alive so this had a precise cold
treatment that killed only the primary
we can determine the temperature that
kills the primary through this
differential thermal analysis method so
we cut the bud off of the cane we put
them in these little chambers in these
plates and then put the plates in a
programmable freezer we slowly freeze
the buds and we measure voltage across
that plate and basically what we're
doing is we're measuring the freezing of
water so as temperature decreases
there's this large spike in voltage as
external water freezes this is a heat
release which changes the voltage of the
plate as the extracellular water freezes
over time as the temperatures are
decreasing the bud is surviving all of
this presumably dehydrating at some
point it's still alive and as long as
you go back and forth between these two
stages freezing and thawing it's fine
when that internal water freezes is it
lethal and that's what we measure here
these little spikes are five primary
buds dying we take the average of that
and then we can plot the survivability
through winter that's what I'm showing
here so here's temperatures these two
curves down here in purple and green are
cab Sauve and Riesling - vanilla
varieties and you can see that you
shaped curve I showed you earlier
acclimation maintenance and d
acclamation so each of these points are
the average of the lethal events for
those buds part of what we're doing is
trying to understand how the buds are
changing through winter because we want
to understand how to maximize their
ability and there are some really cool
models that have come out where they're
trying to predict Bud hardiness so that
farmers have a tool for when they need
to go out and make viticulture
modifications to deal with cold events
the best current model is this Ferguson
model and what I want to show you here
is how bad the Ferguson model is in the
East it works really great in Washington
State or it was developed on like 23
different cultivars what you see here in
black is actual data and then in orange
is the prediction you can see that it
has problems in both early and late
parts of winter in over predicting
hardiness this is the problem if you're
using this as a farming tool and it also
has a hard pan it can't the buds can't
gain hardiness past a certain level so
we're working with this model and the
different aspects of cold hardiness to
try to correct it and then also learn a
bit more about phenotype what I'm
showing here are three years of data for
three different species and blue is
Vitis vinifera in green and yellow or
Vitus riparian Vitus Emmure Ensis those
two species are very cold hardy one from
north america one from asia in 2012-2013
it's a very warm year
actually before we get into that let's
look at some general trends what we see
with our data are cold hardness data is
that when you have a cold event in
winter the buds tend to respond by
gaining cold hardiness when you have a
warming event they tend to respond by
losing cold hardiness but it's not
always true at all points in the winter
so you can see in this particular year
the first cold event resulted in
acclamation the second cold event only
resulted in acclamation in the yellow
cultivar in this year the trend is
reversed the first cold event had no
effect the second one dead so we're
trying to figure out what what makes
these cold events different what is the
vine actually cueing off of
if we look at my disputes a little more
integrated cold in the middle line you
mean they're all working together doing
the same thing well it looks like the
environment was a little colder in the
middle one than in the right ones oh
here yeah well between these three years
they're actually three perfect perfect
comparisons this is a very warm year we
had one cold event this is this is the
freezing point here and these are
minimum temperatures in this year we had
very punctuated winter very cold warm
very cold warm and this year we had
tremendous sustained cold I'm not sure
if you were if you were all here for
this but this was like the two and a
half months of nothing but freezing so
they're very different winters from the
vines point of view if you look at a
mere inches maximum cold hardiness
across those three years what I want you
to notice as it moves in each year it's
in a different position and arrow points
the point in winter when it was at mass
you can see that that arrow moves as
well if you look at the other two
varieties now in comparison you can see
if you phenotype for this trait in a
warm year there's no difference between
these three species if you use a
punctuated year Bennifer it suddenly
looks sensitive and the two wild species
look tolerant and then if you go to a
very cold year you start seeing
separation across all three species this
makes it really challenging to study
from a point of view because so much of
the phenotype is derived from the
environment so the type of winter nests
the type of winter is determining the
cold hardiness in any given year the
other thing to note is that the buds
don't automatically super cool or gain
the maximum amount of freeze hardiness
and every year they need to be pushed so
it's not an automatic on/off switch we
want we still want to understand what
the genetic architecture of this trade
is though because we need to provide
tools to the farmers so we did the same
thing as I did with the dormancy we
looked at 43 different ripe areas to see
if we could understand what's going on
this is what the data looks like it's 43
different curves through winter if you
take all of that data and you load it
into some statistical modeling you can
get a simplified version of what's going
on and so that's what I'm showing here
in
is the least hearty ripe area and yellow
is the most hardy ripe area and there's
about five degrees of tolerance
difference in those two genotypes the
other forty-one accessions are somewhere
in between
so the interesting thing here is if you
you act asked the statistical model is
there specific is there significant
differences between the most and least
cold-hearty there is in this five degree
parameter but not in the shape of the
curve so that means that at any one
point in the winter the least Hardy and
the most Hardy are responding to
temperature perception in the same way
they're gaining relatively amount the
same relative amount of their phenotype
both down and up in response to
temperature so it's not really we're not
really seeing a difference here in a
cold hardiness trait we're seeing a
difference in something that happens
before we start this experiment we
started this experiment as soon as the
leaves fall in in the fall what we think
is going on is that the time that these
vines are shutting down is the time that
they start tracking temperature and
they're able to take advantage of cues
telling them to go cold hardy and I use
an analogy of starting on a track race
where some runners start out ahead and
instead of them all looping around are
doing the same distance imagine it's
just a straight line so whoever starts
winter first has the greatest potential
for the cold hardiness in that year if
we if we run the model backwards so now
we're just guessing at what's going on
we see about a 2-week difference in what
we think these lines are going to sleep
so now we're starting to turn our eyes
away from this particular part of the
trait and more towards this part another
thing I want to bring up here is an
interesting observation that has come
out of viticulture literature if you
spray a vine with ABA when the fruit is
setting you can actually induce cold
hardiness but the interesting thing you
do is you induce it in a parallel
fashion so if you spray a variety with
ABA it goes dormant a little bit earlier
and it gains cold hardiness throughout
the winter in a parallel fashion much
like we're seeing here so this might be
some evidence that this early
acclimation early dormancy is what we
really need to be looking at so
genetics point of view and a genetic
mapping point of view the question is
how do you work with this trait because
it's it's an unwieldy crop it's highly
influenced by the environment when we
make crosses because the winters are
severe here we're always crossing sort
of a moderately cold hardy bhaiyya
very cold hardy so our phenotypic
separation is really bad we really want
to be making this cross so the way that
we've approached it in my group because
I can't grow sensitive vines here
they'll die every year is to break it
down into bits so if we just focus on
the acclamation we want to understand
how do cold events trigger gains of cold
hardiness some things that we know
colder winters give you more hardiness
so colder temperatures should give you
more hardiness we want to know if all
temperatures trigger acclamation in the
same way and if we can develop any new
phenotyping so if you do this as a
thought experiment if you take dormant
cuttings from the field and you put them
into different growth chambers and you
give them different temperatures you
should see differences in acclamation
that's what's pictured here so maybe we
just phenotype all in the growth chamber
when we look at what happens if we do
that with Chardonnay in this case so
this is Chardonnay in the field
this is Chardonnay in the growth chamber
at 2 & 7 we see that there's although
there's a separation there in those
best-fit lines there's no actual
difference between these two responses
if we look at the temperature in this
first two data points we see that in the
field it was 7 degrees Celsius on
average so it should be like the yellow
line but we see acclamation so we're
missing something
if we look at what temperature looks
like in the field here's the 7 average
we're actually seeing a lot of movement
right around that 7 average so maybe
it's the temperature swing so we did the
experiment put them in a growth chamber
with it averaged 7 with a 5 degree swing
just like outside so here's the data and
static temperature here's the data and
static versus cycle so this is really
cool they all gained cold hardiness and
this is a significant gain of cold
hardiness if you cycle the temperature
so they're not paying attention to the
average temperature there's something
about the lows and highs that is
signaling to the vine to gain cold
hardiness the other neat thing that's
here is the - so this is at 2 degrees
Celsius and then we moved it into a
cycling chamber which means we actually
moved it into a warmer environment
because the mean is now 7 and it gained
cold hardiness so it's actually blind
estatic temperatures they don't do
anything from this we're able to come up
with a new parameter called Sigma T so
it's basically looking at the
fluctuations in temperature and when we
add that to the model we fix the
acclimation problem here so what they're
missing in the Washington model that we
have here is that erratic high-low
cycling in Washington it's much more
constant so now what we're doing is now
that we know how to actually make them
acclimate we're trying to look at the
gene expression profiles that are going
on during this process so we're
collecting the tissues now cuz we
finally sort of narrowed in on the
telomeres Network so that'll be I'll
come back and talk in a couple years let
you know how that goes the other side of
this is D acclimation and D acclimation
this is a little bit easier to
understand here it's the response to
binds to warm temperature if we look at
I bring up chilling hours again because
as you gain chilling hours you gain
faster growth and if we look at the
budburst phenotype in a growth chamber
what we're actually looking at us is two
things combined its how fast it takes to
grow but it we're also looking at how
much time it takes to lose cold
hardiness to get to a growth state right
so it's two parts if we look at the
number of days to lose cold hardiness we
see this sort of relationship that if
you test at several different
temperatures so you take cuttings you
put them in two different growth
chambers you measure how fast do they
lose hardiness we see a linear response
at any one temperature so this is a lot
easier than the cycling if we look at
our again our curve and this box
indicates the temperatures we're
chilling accumulates if you go out to
the field and collect material
throughout winter at this point and you
put it in a warm temperature and you try
to deactivate it won't deactivate it
will not lose cold hardiness as you go
through winter that changes the longer
winter goes the more chilling that goes
the deactivation becomes faster at that
given temperature and so what we're
seeing is this relationship between
chill accumulation and D acclimation
speed whereas you are always capable of
D acclimating but in the beginning
you're really really slow and the reason
we're using planes is because I don't
have a mathematical mind and I have to
work with cartoons to understand this
but basically at the beginning of winter
D acclimation is like a plane taxiing
it's moving but it's moving really
really slow
as a games chillin it takes off and then
it meat makes its maximum speed what we
think is going on is these sections
represent those eco dormancy or
endodermis seed transition and eco
dormancy periods
the other thing to note about this is
while these are linear responses the
rate at low temperature is lower than
the rate at high temperature so if your
D acclimating at a low temperature your
decla mating at a lower optimal rate so
full-speed depends on the airplane the
rate of D acclamation depends on the
temperature your D acclimating at so if
we look at Cabernet Sauvignon and you D
acclimate it at 10 degrees Celsius as
chills as chilling accumulates you can
see this response it'll lose about half
a degree of hardiness per day but if you
D acclimate it at 22 degrees Celsius
it'll lose one and a half so it's not a
linear relationship based on temperature
the other thing interesting thing is if
you look at cultivar differences
Riesling d acclimates a little bit
faster at 10 C
and a lot faster at 22 C so depending on
this profile will give you an idea of
how fast you'll break in the spring it's
a reflection of how you're responding to
warming temperatures if we take those
parameters now cultivar specific D
acclamation parameters and plug them
into the model we fix the tail end of
the model so we've captured the two
portions of this response that are
unique well it's not unique to the
Northeast we see it in the Northeast
because our temperatures are more
variable
the other thing I want to show you is
how this compares to other species
so here's Cabernet Sauvignon again 10
and 22 here's Riesling if you look at
vitae Sam you're Ensis so this is the
wild species they use for cold hardy
breeding in Asia it diakonos at 10 C at
the same rate as caps off does at 22
it's incredibly timed as soon as there's
the slightest bit warming it gets ready
to break bud this is a serious problem
if you include this trait in a hybrid in
an area like New York at 22 C its it's
off the charts right pareo which is our
our favorite cold hardy species in North
America is also faster than recently in
cab sub it's not as not as fast as by
December ANSYS but if you look at it at
22 C it catches up so the relative
differences between these species are
it's really interesting to to see that
there are different components of this
phenotype itself what we learned from
this from a genetic mapping kind of
approach is that we now have a phenotype
that we can look at if we're trying to
select for increased responsiveness to
temperature or decreased responsiveness
of temperature typically here we want
decreased response so that we don't have
early budburst
but for table grapes in Southern
California they want tea acclamation
that really really rapidly acclamation
because they don't have long winters so
we now know we want to phenotype at
around 1,500 hours of chill but we also
see that northern species are bringing
along along with cold hardiness they're
bringing along this rapid d acclamation
phenotype that we don't really want so
now I have to somehow break those two
things apart that's possible how this
bears out when you look at data so now
this is the same data I showed you
before but now I color-coded it to match
here as you can see based on the
responsiveness of M urine sassette 10 C
why we have so much loss in midwinter in
a mere Ensis and we don't see the same
loss in ripe area but at the end of the
season when chilling has maximized we're
starting to warm up we start to see the
same same levels of D acclamation so it
starts to make sense with the field data
so another cool observation that comes
out of this is looking at these three
varieties so Cab Franc and Sauvignon
Blanc are two and cabs are burnin yon
Cabernet Sauvignon are three varieties
that happen to have this pedigree Cab
Franc and South Blanc are the parents of
caps off it so we have sort of like a
local small breeding family to look at
if we look at their response here soft
Blanc at ten and twenty two
here's Cab Franc at ten and twenty two
and here's cab saw at ten and twenty two
so what's neat about this is it tells us
that we really want to be perhaps
phenotyping at this warm temperature
because we can exaggerate the
differences between genotypes
but then comparing it with a colder
temperature may give us a better idea of
what they're doing at different stages
and so we could be selecting for
different aspects of the stray
the other thing we're doing with D
acclamation is the same thing I
mentioned in acclamation is that we're
collecting data on gene expression and
so as the vine is d acclimate d
acclimating we collect bud tissue and do
RNA RNA seek on those samples we did
this on four different varieties
Riesling caps off Emmy rensis and ripe
area and this is a heat map which I
don't
it looks really washed out but um I'm
sure you've seen heat maps from gene
expression before basically if we look
at how time affects this we have a major
group of genes that are upregulated
during D acclamation and a major group
of genes that are down regulated excuse
me when we do pathway enrichment like
which how many genes are in different
pathways are there any over-represented
pathways but one thing that popped out
repeatedly in all four varieties is the
ABA pathway and so in the ABA pathway we
have carotenoid biosynthesis leading is
an Thaksin getting two ABA ABA can then
be degraded signal or be put in an
activation reactivation pool and if we
look at how gene expression occurs each
day during D acclamation so that's what
these squares are you can see that
biosynthesis is shut down conversion is
shut down degradation is shut down
signaling a shutdown and the inactive
pool is the only thing that is sort of
being upregulated so it's sort of like
the vine or the bud is purging ABA this
makes sense from what we know about the
antagonistic aspects of ABA and GA ABA
represses ga-ga is were responsible for
growth that's what's happening during d
acclamation is a gradual conversion from
no growth to growth so this makes a lot
of sense so what we wanted to do from
and this is by no means complete this is
just like the easiest nugget to show you
what we've done though is we've taken
this result and we've moved it into
trying to translate this into a bit of
culture method for growers and so what
we did is we looked at the effect of ABA
on the on the phenotype of D acclamation
so if you look at the normal
deactivation pattern here in yellow you
can see over time you lose cold
hardiness
if you spray the buds with an ABA spray
you can stop D acclamation and shift
this port the bud break phenotype by
quite quite a distance here it's like a
30 days if you look at what that looks
like from the grouse plant look here on
the left is control here's 1 millimolar
ABA 5 miller molar ABA you can see that
there's a clear suppression of growth
and a clear delay relative to control
the other thing that we're doing is
comparing this to methyl jasmine 8
another stress responsive hormone to see
if we could trigger similar pathways
with a different plant hormone you can
see here in 5 millimolar methyl Jasmine
8 and 2.5 millimolar methyl jessamine
that we're getting some of the same
phenotype but it's not as Extreme as ABA
and so we've hope we've dissected the
the different aspects of cold hardiness
apart with the goal of trying to come up
with genes that are important but then
also give growers maybe a field
mitigation method should we have warm
events in in late winter
so just to wrap all of this up dormancy
acclimation maintenance of coal hardness
and d acclamation are a suite of
physiological and genetic traits it's
all very complex temperature perception
is clearly playing a major role we don't
know what the temperature the tension
temperature sensor is in the bud there's
not a lot of actively growing tissue but
something is keeping track of
temperature acclamation is far more
complicated than just perceiving an
average temperature temperature so it's
not just colder gives you more
acclamation there's colder and variable
temperature swings that gives you a
clinician the acclamation and chilling
requirement they appear to be adaptive
and we seem to have a really nice
phenotype now for deploying to mapping
studies so one of the problems with
grapes is that we don't have a if you
make a mapping family you don't have a
lot of space for your plants and you
don't have a lot of tissue from any one
individual and so this might give us a
way to finally start phenotyping because
we've narrowed in on something that
actually changes in a consistent way and
finally Cizek acid metabolism seems to
play an essential role both in the
acclimation as i showed you if you spray
with ABA they gain hardiness but also in
d acclamation that if you supply ABA you
can halt so I know that was a lot but I
will just say thank you for giving me a
chance to talk and then open it up to
her any questions
I mean with prep area is there not
variations out there and the natural one
that you could actually in these cold
winters go through and score death and
essentially do a natural Association
that be designed so essentially go
through after a hard winter to figure
out which one's died and you find 10
5000 them look like I could go through
woods and just then just gia type live
and hit was that yes so the question was
Google
yes so the question was could we
basically do a natural selection study
collect impassive of very variable
genotypes for ripe area plant them all
out hopefully kill a good chunk of them
and then just look for the genetic
regions that are shared sure you walk in
the woods can you score the desert area
in the woods not easily and the the
problem we see with the ripe areas so
all of those right periods survive here
whether they come from Texas where they
come from Manitoba they survive here so
we and I showed you in the very cold
year we can start pushing things that
are cold hardy apart your study design
might work better if you were to take a
whole diversity panel and put it in
Manitoba right where we where we really
push up against the adaptive barrier at
45 degrees or the 40 degrees C line we
need that kind of winter the kind of
winters we have just make things messy
we don't we don't normally see any
damage in ripe area we will see it in
vinifera but again it depends on the
year in some years we have significant
benefit damage at what would be
considered warm temperatures because it
was a very mild winter and so it's just
it's really sticky but I think you could
do it a principle if you put it
someplace where you pushed yeah
thanks a lot so in genomic prediction
people are trying to integrate progress
models with creation for things like
yields and you know it depends on having
a very simplified crop growth model so
you only have a few parameters that you
think are under genetic control and then
you you push those through crop growth
model and I mean I guess you showed me
showed the various graphs where you're
trying to match exclamation that
Commission estimates you're developing a
winter parting this model is it's three
year different phases I mean you think
you can simplify it or is it already
slide down two three four maybe five
parameters that each each you and you
essentially try to give each genotype
that you have in succession a value for
you know three or four parameters and
then appreciating that model so that's
the goal so the the way the Keller model
was developed is similar to what you're
saying and that for each cultivar you
have a set of parameters that you just
plug and chug given your weather data
like you just send it through with the
data that I presented that's only we
only have it for two varieties and this
is stuff that's come out of Al's project
but that's the end goal so it's and it's
connecting those two pieces right
because we have temperature playing a
different role in each section and it's
all related to the chill accumulation so
the hope would be that we'd be able to
have like a parameter that ties to
acclamation a parameter that is
measuring the chill accumulation which
is fairly standard it's the temperature
range and then the the rates of D
acclamation so if you string those
together you should get the curve based
on any given year right it's going to be
dependent on temperature so we're
working towards that now that we know
that it works and it's worth the effort
it's actually a fairly simple experiment
to go out and do and collect all the
material and then just 43 you know with
the important part is to do the growth
chamber experiments
in both cases because the natural
variation there's too much other stuff
going on there and I didn't show here
there's other aspects of like when the
Sun is out the buds are actually warmer
than air temperature at night the butts
drop a low air temperature so there's
all these other environmental parameters
that we need to narrow things in the
growth chamber in order to understand
how to incorporate them for the field so
for the for the ripe area stuff we
haven't done the controlled like d
acclamation studies at different
temperatures to get the rates for every
every variety we only have it for that
one that I showed him that that graph
but that's where we're gonna go next
because all the stuff I started with was
using these older cold hardiness curves
and and budburst assays and and frankly
the new methods are a lot a lot tighter
and so we're gonna redo that so that we
can actually use those parameters I'm
sorry one more Ben you very slow speeds
is there anything that has those two
combinations I really hope so
the acclamation side of things from from
the comparisons I've done for past stuff
they look like they acclimate roughly at
the same rate so it may be that there's
more of a it's a more constant response
to temperature on that side of it that
part of the physiology may be more
standard in the D acclimation maybe the
wiggly part
rapid acclamation right now we're faced
with trying to figure out how
temperature with certain amplitude gives
you certain hardiness and that actually
gets tricky because as you go down and
temperature gets harder and harder to
actually simulate that winter so I don't
know how far we'll get to figuring out
if we can get rapid acclimate errs but
the hope would be get something that
goes down and each year gets you your
maximum hardiness so that means going to
sleep early and then your maximum
resistance to D acclamation I think that
would be the the best way forward
because we're not gonna be able to
control winters and every now and then
we're gonna have a winter that kills
them because it's mild and then we get a
polar vortex I don't really think
there's anything we can do to prevent
that so we just give you the best tools
for each year
and you had a question nobody has done a
good job of showing that that's possible
so the rootstock could impact cold
hardiness from maybe some other ways by
controlling buying bigger or by
controlling sort of like the crop load
contributing to a greater or lesser crop
load and that may have a source sync
relationship with with bud cold
hardiness Tim Martinson is the extension
viticulturist at Cornell and G is doing
a study right now with the idea of
testing the source sync idea if you
dramatically reduce sinks or you
dramatically reduce sources can you
influence bud cold hardiness I don't
like no one has shown that a given root
stock will improve the cold hardiness of
Riesling by X and really I don't know if
that's possible I've never done it but
the but itself is sort of isolated from
the root part of the dormancy process
and the hardiness process is sealing
itself off from the cane so that ice
can't propagate into the bud and so
signals and that kind of stuff that
might be coming from the root are going
to be difficult to transmit into the bud
outside of the growing season but yeah
just know once I've done good systematic
job of it first one to start winning the
race yeah but me and you you you start
to activate voice earlier is there a
relationship to say that right and that
was with ripe area data right so we
haven't we would have to look to see
what the projected dormancy target would
be for a Bennifer
to see how close that would push up
against harvest date
so with right period we're not we have
never eat we don't even look at yield
because we just don't we're looking at
it more from the hardness point of view
when they do the studies with ABA and
they sprayed they spray the vines at
brazen which is the when the berry start
to turn purple it's sort of midseason I
guess they see the effect in the fall
with yellowing of leaves early leaf drop
early entrance into dormancy but it also
ripens the berries faster so the ABA
ripens the berries faster so may be
possible to select for yields like
earlier ripening phenotype in tandem
with oh okay but no you know related
things that are gonna go into growth the
next year okay yeah so your question is
would would speeding up entrance into
dormancy impact the subsequent year's
harvest um
I don't know how much I guess that's a
great question I don't know the right
answer I guess we would talk to like a
fruit load physiologist right I don't
know how much those late season leaves
are contributing to the photosynthate
storage where if you were to knock him
off a couple weeks early if you would I
don't think he would impact
inflorescence number because they're
already patterned in the buds
so I don't I don't know the right answer
to that once we figure out the first
part and we'll go after that this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at cornell edu